so I've been doing some interviews here
and there lately and because I haven't
been doing that this year as you guys
know mainly print and I've been asked
how do you authentically uh deliver a
message and something hit me in the
interview that I just did that I felt
like I should look now in video horn of
course um I'm a salesman and I'm really
[ __ ] proud of it and what I've come to
realize is the reason 99% of the things
that I see out there are struggling with
authenticity is that people are scared
to accept being a Salesman I don't know
I always thought of myself growing up as
a salesman and as an entrepreneur and
you know 10 years ago saying you're an
entrepreneur meant that you were
freaking loser and you did ten random
things and didn't make a dollar really
and it's amazing for me to see being an
entrepreneur has become this like cool
like think that people want to say they
are oh by the way news alert all the
entrepreneurs that are running around
right now a lot of them just aren't just
the way it is anyway on that note I
think it's time for people to understand
that it's okay to be a salesperson
if you sell stuff it's just the world
you know they're a part of the ecosystem
I'm one of them I'm a Salesman I've been
one my whole life and I'm proud of it
and I know a lot of people out there
that are are trying to disguise or hide
it in their in their presentation in a
public persona or how they communicate
to the world I think it's a mistake the
only way to be authentic is to be
[ __ ] authentic